different sort of childhood because one
parent doesn't have the other person to
like bounce off like they can be too
strict or too lacks and i do think
that's a real thing
but i do think that you can get married
and be in a committed relationship
and have a child and then without a
child also be in a committed
relationship with the child you know i
think you missed a question i asked if
you give me an honest respect for every
question i asked if marriage is easy
before forget the children for now
you're married someone it doesn't work
out after three or four years you walk
away no problems right
that's easy having a child or something
wherever you're married you have ever
tried someone wherever that guy's a
[ __ ] and you hate him after a year
he realized he wasn't the one for you
yeah right you're still have a link to
that man for 18 years at least so why
would you get mad why would you not get
married first
and will could maybe be able to walk
away with lesser commitment than have a
child it's a greater commitment i feel
like somebody that's like kind of a
special case i haven't really i mean i
don't know really what situations are
but i feel like usually when you have
the child before me are just like not
intentional maybe like my people like my
parents
[Music]
like i mean that's not a bad thing and
then you can like you can still like
like i mean obviously you still like
choose to keep it but i mean it doesn't
i feel like it's just a special case i
think that now that we're having
children so much later in life yeah i
feel like it doesn't matter so we're a
bit mature like the average age to have
a child now it's probably a lot older
than when my parents would have a child
i think that's why it doesn't really
matter when exactly the child is born
because normally it's later than the
average anyway i've got parents
sorry i just think like you can't
there's no way you can accidentally have
a child in
2022 you know you do all the right
things and then you still get pregnant
and then like you know maybe they don't
want to have the abortion so they choose
to have the kid but then you know they
don't feel like quite ready they're
gonna be unhappy so you're telling me
like condoms and birth control you know
someone that's gotten pregnant on both
but also i mean like not everyone takes
birth control not everyone wears condoms
that's oh we're in the uk now right i
don't know how it is for your
internationals
but in the uk
and i'll stand by this and people can
ask me what they want to
you cannot have a baby packs in the uk
you can have a word you cannot you can
say it you can not have a child by
accident in the uk
well i mean i used to have a child in uk
because yeah contraception is free
condoms the pills we're getting right
now wait wait let me finish quantums are
free the pill is free
if you don't have that you have you get
reckless
one nafta is free
everything in the uk in terms of
reproductive rights are free so if you
choose to do any of those things you
have made a conscious decision to have a
child yes over here you cannot try
backstage but i didn't say by accident i
said unintentionally
so you can no it's not because yeah like
naivety like something can happen that
you're not aware of let's say you're not
conscious well let's say like you are
very naive you don't know to monitor
your cycle you don't know if you've
misappeared some people just don't pay
attention to those things there's people
who have abortions are free
yeah some people don't even know they're
pregnant yeah so like abortion so you
chose to have a child but okay but
that's the thing
you choose you choose oh you let me talk
so i'm not saying like it was by
accident i'm saying they unintentionally
got pregnant and then they chose right
against their values to like have an
abortion so like it wasn't even a choice
let's say
yeah
it's not a choice but some some people
it's not even choice they wouldn't think
about having an abortion it's not on the
table let's say they're very catholic
well that's that's how my parents were
but but but
no um like my parents my parents my mom
got pregnant when she was um 17 but she
still chose to give up that kid for
adoption so like you still have adoption
even if you have the kid do you know in
the bible it talks about having adopted
um having abortions
i don't know where that's coming from
like
whether the numbers directly i believe
numbers nine says if you're up and
someone can look it up and give the
exact bibles a reference well i think
it's number nine is something says
something in the lines of if you have a
wife and you believe she's cheating as a
baby she should go see like a witch
doctor take a potion and get rid of the
baby so the bible talks about having a
what does that mean for people that
aren't religious like you're saying that
you put religion up i didn't bring
religion out who brought up having a
abuser as you know i did say i mentioned
that some people don't believe that what
i'm saying some people like she's saying
that some people don't believe in
abortion so that's why they choose to do
it some people can't afford some people
can't afford an abortion so let's say
this doesn't take no no you're in the uh
but we're talking about the yeah
i'm just saying in the uk there's not
the funding of it isn't an issue because
you have the nhs you have to worry about
the funding of it it's not that's not
that it's not a debate with but some you
know what is there some issues some some
fears some females choose to like keep
the baby for the food like
it's it's the right reasons for them but
it's the wrong reasons for the guy
because what they're doing is like
um you got me pregnant mm-hmm
i'm gonna keep the baby and i'm just
gonna you know graciously accept your
child donations every month they do you
know what i mean but if you're saying
like if they're not married yet so then
and you said that only once you're
married then they actually have like
something oh you have to pick child
support regardless you have to support
but regardless you're entitled to more
as a wife than your mother
okay okay that's why i see your benefit
to be married first
yeah like because for example my parents
had me there wasn't like there wasn't
married when they had me as well so like
but you also have adoption like you can
give up a kid for adoption if you don't
believe in abortion
that's what my parents did
[Music]
poor greg
he's involved with us now like we we
like read yeah yeah we like yeah that's
what i said like you ended up bringing
him back into your family yeah yeah but
like i respect that someone made a
decision like i can't take care of this
child i'm gonna put them in the hands of
someone that can take care of the child
i really respect that the people that do
that so
kudos too but i i see your parents
but i i still i agree with you like i
think that if you get pregnant it's a
choice on some level you either made the
choice to be irresponsible
and yeah at some level you made that
choice we yeah i think definitely take
accountability yeah your own
contraception your own health and sexual
safety i think that's the bare minimum
do you guys think abortion is used as a
form of birth control today rather than
an emergency i don't think i don't think
so i don't know this is statistics but i
feel like it's kind of a traumatic
experience and i don't think women would
intentionally want to have an abortion
i think i feel like the more like
uneducated people maybe like the more
like then would they use it like for
that but i mean for people that have
gone through like sex ed or whatever
classes like
i mean they know
like what the body is can i just pause
it for a second sex education in high
school in the uk is absolutely atrocious
it
is i am so sorry when i went to high
school and for those of you that went to
high school about maybe
four or five years ago everybody knows
they give you this little
penis plastic and they show you how to
roll on i don't believe that
i don't believe in sex ed in schools
what do you believe in them i believe
that your parents should be in charge of
that i don't think the government should
come in i would not have i could i could
not i
as a girl wouldn't
a girl as a girl you know the creepiest
teachers were always the gym teachers i
think that
i'm scared
i've ever had when have you ever had a
gym teacher teach sex ed it would mostly
be like your homeroom teacher well i
just think i just think okay if you're
like you're giving predators access to
children you're blowing my color right
now what but it doesn't matter no i
don't know i'm gonna be teachers like
period well i know but you can't do it
but i know like you can't filter that
out and i just think like you're giving
predators and act like men and women
predators access to children at a very
young age
and like why like i don't understand
what a stranger is going to teach my
kids better than i can teach them